you know we like to do uh music reviews
on this channel we try to review
the hot new joints whenever they drop
and so forth but we've never reviewed
um any bts songs that is those are those
are the hot joints that we've kind of
we've overlooked and part of the reason
why we've never reviewed anything from
bts is that um well one reason is that i
didn't know bts existed until very
recently and then when someone told me
told me about them i said oh you mean
the serial killer right and they
explained no btk was a serial killer
fine torture kill bts is a korean boy
band and they're a huge global sensation
and i said you mean you mean btk was in
a boy band and they said no you idiot
these are two different things and i
said oh
anyway it's really kind of um inspiring
what bts has done and that they've
they've been able to travel across the
globe and um
you know bring together all kinds of
people all kinds of different people
with bad taste in music
all these different disparate groups
with bad taste and music they can all
kind of come together it doesn't matter
if you're black white boy girl asian
uh transgender whatever you are if you
have bad taste in music
they're here for you
so i kind of appreciate that and to show
my appreciation i will today be
listening to and reviewing the latest
um what i think is the latest bts joint
called butter
let me say one other thing from the jump
here
before we get into the song
i'm told that this is this this group
has a legion of devoted followers an
army of followers they call themselves
the bts army
and uh you don't want to upset them
and i've been warned about that
and and i take that warning seriously
so please allow me to say to uh these
fans if you're watching this i mean no
offense to you
uh and um
i don't want to upset you
and i'm very sorry sorry that you're all
deaf
you know
i know that it has to be difficult
so with that olive branch extended let's
uh let's get into the song this is
butter from bts let's watch
smooth like butter like criminal
undercover young pop like trouble
breaking into your heart like that
cool shake stomach
[Music]
break it down
[Music]
okay so i mean this seems like pretty
standard issue boy band stuff i had to
say i was expecting
um i was i was expecting something else
i don't wanna say expecting more but i
just
i was expecting something more
outrageous
you know to keep up with modern times
uh i thought a boy band music video in
2021 would be a bunch of like
genderless furries cannibalizing each
other or something you'd have to get
really
outrageous and actually they do appear
to be pretty genderless but the point is
i i didn't think that it would look and
sound almost exactly like
in sync 25 years ago
don't get me wrong this is not a
complaint in fact it's sort of it's sort
of comforting in a way
that everything else has changed in the
world you know
everything is changing so quickly and
oftentimes for the worst
but boy bands have remained exactly the
same for 30 years it has not changed one
bit
and so it's it's like an oasis i guess
it's a shelter in the storm
we have the stability of the boyband
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get it let it move
um so question this is and this is
honestly it's an honest question is this
good dancing
is it actually good dancing because i i
feel like
the dancing here is not very good but i
don't know because i can't dance at all
if i tried to dance it would probably
look like i was having an epileptic
episode or something
but i'm not impressed with the dancing
ears especially the one dude who's the
dude there in the in the uh the white
the white uh suit jacket
you know his solo dance he was just
standing there snapping his fingers
half-heartedly not impressed with that
that that's my move if i'm in a wedding
party and you know if you're in a
wedding party and they do the thing like
they do at all weddings now where at the
reception they make you walk in to music
with entrance music and you're supposed
to have this nice little cute little
dance with whatever bridesmaid they've
matched you up with
and so for me it's just that i'm just
doing this as i walk down or maybe i'll
you know i might shake the finger like
this this is my dance you know
that's all i'm doing
so i can appreciate i can relate to that
guy in that way that he can't dance i
can't test but i expect a little bit i
expect a little bit better dancing from
a boy band um okay let's uh we'll we'll
we'll dive back in and watch just a
little bit more of this
i'm the nice guy got the right body in
the right mind rolling up the party at
the right time
[Music]
[Music]
okay
you have a headache uh i
that's about all that i can take i think
that's almost the end of the song goes
on further
you get the idea honestly i would rather
be in a room with the btk killer i think
i'd prefer btk over this and i don't
mean that as an insult okay i no
disrespect intended to these artists or
to their fans
uh i don't mean any insult i'm just
saying that i personally would rather be
tortured and killed by a serial killer
than listen to this for one more second
that's all it's my personal preference
that's all i'm saying
uh but i did appreciate how they got
into a little bit of a rap there and uh
and i i didn't quite understand what
they were saying so i did look up the
lyrics out of curiosity
just because i thought i i don't wanna i
don't wanna miss
the message
and so here's the lyrics that were just
performed for you
ice on my wrist i'm that nice guy
got that right body and that right mind
rolling up to the party
got the right vibe smooth like butter
hate us love us
fresh boy pull up and we lay low
all the players get moving when the bass
low
got army right behind us when we say so
let's go sidestep right left to my beat
i like the moon
rock with me baby
wow that is i mean even by the standards
of pop music that is some
incoherent [ __ ] i've got to say
there there isn't one complete thought
to be found there they're not even
writing
in full sentences at least insync was
basically intelligible you know like i
want to see you out that door baby bye
bye bye you know that that's a classic
lyric that's not shakespeare but it's
comprehensible you understand what
they're trying to say what they're
saying is get the hell out i don't want
to see you okay fine
got that right body and that right mind
what
what are you
first of all who are you taught who who
has the right body and right mind you
you're talking about yourself
because it sounds like from the from the
context you're talking about yourself so
you're saying about yourself
that you got that right body
hey girl i got that right body if you
know what i mean
what
oh don't worry i also have
that right mind
but i guess i should cut them some slack
because english isn't their first
language i realize and all of that all
in all i have to give uh bts
thumbs up
for
not being serial killers i guess as i
had originally believed
but the music i'm afraid gets two thumbs
down